Egal ob ihr Auto fahrt oder auch nicht, die
mal wieder aktuelle Dieseldebatte betrifft
jeden von uns, denn es geht um die Luft, die
wir einatmen.
Doch jetzt kamen Lungenärzte mit diesem Statement
daher, in dem sie sinngemäß behaupten, dass
die aktuellen Grenzwerte Mist seien und das
auch die Angst vor Stickoxiden und Feinstaub
unwissenschaftlich sei.
Mhhhhhh.
Ihr wisst was jetzt kommt, oder?
Holt euch nen Tee, macht es euch gemütlich,
denn wir gehen das hier jetzt in aller Ruhe
durch.
Tja ich kann mir heute leider gar keinen Tee
machen, da ich mich in einem teelosen Hotelzimmer
befinde, aber ich hoffe ihr macht es euch
trotzdem gemütlich.
Fangen wir an mit den gesundheitlichen Basics.
Warum sind Feinstaub und Stickoxide ungesund?
Feinstaub bezeichnet kleinste Partikel im
unteren Mikrometer-Bereich, die durch Einatmen
in den Körper gelangen und dort Entzündungen
auslösen können.
Es gibt primären Feinstaub, der entsteht
direkt durch Verbrennungsprozesse oder durch
Abrieb; und es gibt sekundären Feinstaub,
der entsteht durch chemische Reaktionen.
Also Landwirtschaft, Industrie produzieren
viel Feinstaub, aber eben auch Verkehr - sei
es durch Reifenabrieb oder durch Abgase.
Jetzt kann Feinstaub verschiedenste chemische
Zusammensetzungen haben, die sind weniger
entscheidend als die Partikelgröße.
Je kleiner desto gefährlicher, kann man sagen.
Ab einer Größe von 2,5μm abwärts wirds
besonders gefährlich; man bezeichnet diese
Partikel als "PM2,5".
"PM" steht für "Particulate Matter".
Feinstaub kann das Risiko für Schlaganfälle
und Herzinfarkte erhöhen.
Mit im Portfolio sind außerdem Lungenkrebs,
Asthma, Allergien und generelle Atembeschwerden.
Dann die "Stickoxide".
Stickoxide sind Gase, die bei Verbrennungen
entstehen.
Zum Beispiel in Industrieanlagen, Heizanlagen
oder eben auch in Automotoren.
In Städten kommen 60% der Stickoxide aus
Verkehrsabgasen.
Genau genommen sind es zwei Gase, nämlich
Stickstoffmonoxid "NO" und Stickstoffdioxid
"NO2"; werden oft zusammengefasst unter "NOX"
- habt ihr vielleicht auch schon gehört.
Beide Gase entstehen bei Autoabgasen, nur
wird NO ziemlich schnell in NO2 umgewandelt,
weswegen NO2 das relevantere Gas von beiden
ist.
Und dieses Gas ist mehrfach problematisch:
es ist zunächst giftig und ätzend und kann
Lungenschäden verursachen.
Eine langfristige Aussetzung kann aber auch
zu chronischen und allergischen Atemwegserkrankungen
führen und wirkt sich auch auf die Gesamtsterblichkeit
aus.
Doch auch die chemischen Reaktionen von NO2
sind problematisch; mit Wasser reagiert es
zu Salpetersäure, das schadet Böden und
Gewässern; es kann auch Ozon bilden, also
bodennahes Ozon, was auch nicht so toll ist.
Und es kann zum Beispiel Ammoniumnitrat bilden,
das in Form von feinsten Partikeln - also
"Feinstaub" - die Luft verschmutzt; das heißt
NO2 ist auch ein sogenanntes "Vorläufergas"
für Feinstaub.
Tja und Dieselautos stoßen besonders viel
Stickoxide aus.
Viel mehr als Benziner.
Viele politische Fragen - eine wissenschaftliche
Grundlage.
Here is the tea.. also hier ist kein Tee,
aber ihr wisst...
Alle politischen Debatten basieren auf einer
wissenschaftlichen Grundlage: nämlich, dass
die Stickstoff- und Feinstaubkonzentrationen,
die wir jetzt hier auf den Straßen einatmen,
gesundheitsschädlich sind.
Wenn sie das nicht wären, müssten wir auch
nicht über Dieselfahrverbote diskutieren.
Und genau bei dieser Basis greift jetzt dieses
Statement ein.
Denn hierin heißt es, dass die Grenzwerte,
die derzeit in Deutschland gelten, nicht gerechtfertigt
seien.
Und dass es deswegen auch keinen Handlungsbedarf
gäbe, so lange diese Grenzwerte nicht neu
bestimmt würden.
Das schreiben Professor Dieter Köhler und
drei weitere Autoren, das sind zwei Lungenärzte
und zwei Ingenieure und sie werden unterstützt
durch eine Unterschriftenliste von rund hundert
Profs und Doktoren.
Die Medien stürzen sich auf dieses Statement
und Dieter Köhler wurde bisher schon in viele
öffentlich-rechtliche Talkshows und Nachrichtensendungen
eingeladen.
Und unser Bundesverkehrsminister Andreas Scheuer
sagte: "Der Aufruf der Lungenärzte muss dazu
führe, dass die Umsetzung der Grenzwerte
hinterfragt und gegebenenfalls verändert
wird."
Und dass er sich freue, dass sich so viele
Experten zusammengeschlossen haben, um nochmal
Fakten in die Debatte zu bringen und damit
eine Versachlichung.
(wütendes Rhinozeros)
Ich brauch Tee.
Gehen wir es mal durch.
Die Stellungnahme - Absatz für Absatz.
Okay ab geht die Party.
Die Stellungnahme beginnt mit ein paar Ergebnissen
aus der bisherigen Forschung und ein paar
Zahlen daraus.
In Abschnitt 2 werden diese Zahlen in Frage
gestellt, denn schließlich sähen die Lungenärzte
in ihren Praxen und Kliniken Todesfälle an
COPD - das steht für "Chronisch Obstruktive
Lungenkrankheit" - und Lungenkrebs täglich.
Jedoch Tote durch Feinstaub und NOX, auch
bei sorgfältiger Anamnese, nie.
Eine Anamnese ist eine professionelle medizinische
Befragung, da ist klar, dass man so Sachen
wie Rauchen besser nachvollziehen kann, als
Luftverschmutzung.
"Wie viel rauchen sie im Schnitt pro Tag?"
"Drei bis vier Zigaretten."
"Mhh und wie viel Stickoxid atmen sie so ein?"
"...ähm"
Also natürlich kann man stattdessen
fragen, ob die Person zum Beispiel an einer
viel befahrenen Straße wohnt.
Trotzdem verrät so eine Info einem Lungenarzt
nicht so viel wie etwa die Anzahl der Zigaretten,
die ein Raucher angibt.
Denn ein Lungenkrebspatient ist mit einer
Wahrscheinlichkeit von 85% Raucher, weil man
durchs Rauchen einfach so hohe Konzentrationen
an schädlichen Stoffen inhaliert.
Der Effekt ist so stark, dass auch ein Lungenarzt
in seiner kleinen Praxis deutlich sehen kann,
dass ein Zusammenhang zwischen Rauchen und
Lungenkrebs besteht.
Im Gegensatz dazu wird bei Luftverschmutzung,
also bei den Konzentrationen von Stickoxiden
und Feinstaub über die wir hier reden, das
Krankheitsrisiko deutlich weniger erhöht.
Wir haben hier viel geringere Konzentrationen,
aber dafür ständig und über einen sehr
langen Zeitraum.
Die Effekte sind so klein, dass ein normal
praktizierender Lungenarzt das in seiner Praxis
mit ein paar Hundert Patienten nicht sehen
wird.
Also es wird ihm nicht auffallen.
Fazit: natürlich sehen sie keine Feinstaubtoten,
weil man sie als praktizierender Lungenarzt
auch gar nicht sehen kann.
Deswegen schaut man sich viel größere Gruppen
von Menschen über einen viel längeren Zeitraum
an, in sogenannten "Epidemiologischen Studien".
Und genau diese Studien werden in diesem Statement
jetzt kritisiert.
So ab Absatz 3 geht's jetzt los.
Hier steht, die Studien hätten einen systematischen
Fehler.
Was die Autoren hier kritisieren, sind die
sogenannten "Methoden" dieser Studien.
Also die Art und Weise der Datenerhebung und
der Auswertung.
Das ist prinzipiell ein wichtiger Punkt und
wenn ihr meinen Kanal schon länger schaut,
dann wisst ihr vielleicht auch schon, dass
wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse wenig aussagen,
so lange ihr nicht wisst, wie diese Ergebnisse
entstanden sind.
Also wie sind die Ergebnisse über Feinstaub
und Stickoxide entstanden?
Ein klassisches Studiendesign wäre eine sogenannte
"Kohortenstudie".
Bei einer Kohortenstudie nehme ich eine möglichst
große Gruppe von Menschen, die zum Beispiel
an verschieden stark befahrenen Straßen wohnen.
Stadtmenschen vs.
Landmenschen.
Dann beobachte ich diese Menschen jahrelang
oder jahrzehntelang und schaue, ob diejenigen,
die jetzt mehr Stickoxiden oder mehr Feinstaub
ausgesetzt sind, über die Jahre auch häufiger
Krankheiten entwickeln.
Oder ob sie früher sterben als ihre Lebenserwartung
wäre.
Und hier kommen wir zu Kritikpunkt 1: Korrelation
und Kausalität.
Beispiel: Sagen wir in meiner Kohortenstudie
beobachte ich, dass Menschen, die an stark
befahrenen Straßen leben, im Schnitt früher
sterben.
Außerdem sind Menschen an stark befahrenen
Straßen mehr Feinstaub ausgesetzt.
Dann "kann" der Feinstaub Ursache für das
frühe Sterben sein, "muss" aber nicht.
Denn an viel befahrenen Straßen gibt es ja
auch mehr Luftverschmutzung als nur Feinstaub.
Außerdem kann es sein, dass Menschen, die
in der City leben, ein generell stressigeres
Leben führen.
Oder vielleicht rauchen Menschen in Städten
mehr oder trinken mehr Alkohol, wer weiß?
Bei einer Kohortenstudie kommen also immer
mehrere Faktoren zusammen und deswegen kann
man immer nur "Korrelationen" feststellen.
Also Dinge die zusammen auftreten, aber keine
"Kausalitäten" - also Ursache-Wirkungsbeziehungen.
Und das kritisieren Köhler und Kollegen,
sie sagen Korrelationen sind keine Kausalitäten.
Und damit haben sie auch erst mal Recht.
Aber sie gehen weiter und sagen: "Korrelationen
dienen nur der Hypothesenbildung, sie sind
nie konfirmatorisch."
Und das stimmt so nicht.
Man kann das so pauschal nicht sagen; ich
muss immer schauen, wie nah Korrelation und
Kausalität zusammenliegen.
In manchen Fällen haben sie gar nichts miteinander
zu tun.
Zum Beispiel korreliert die Anzahl der Todesfälle
durch Ertrinken im Pool mit der Anzahl der
Nicolas Cage-Filme.
Aber Korrelation und Kausalität können auch
sehr nah beieinander liegen.
Das habe ich hier auch schon mal erklärt.
Und trotzdem wäre es falsch zu sagen, dass
man mit Korrelationen keine Ursachen erschließen
kann.
Bei Zucker und Diabetes Typ 2 zum Beispiel
gibt es inzwischen so viele verschiedene Studien,
die sich gegenseitig bestätigen und die einhergehen
mit allem was wir über den Zuckerstoffwechsel
wissen und herausgefunden haben, so dass man
mit gutem Gewissen sagen kann: ein hoher Zuckerkonsum
begünstigt Diabetes Typ 2.
Was will ich jetzt damit sagen?
Korrelation ist nicht automatisch gleich Kausalität,
aber Korrelation ist auch nicht automatisch
ungleich Kausalität.
Man muss also von Fall zu Fall entscheiden
und im Fall Stickoxide und im Fall Feinstaub
sind sich die Experten einig, dass die Summe
der Daten eine Gesundheitsschädlichkeit klar
belegt.
Und zwar nicht nur belegt durch Korrelationen
aus Kohortenstudien, sondern zum Beispiel
auch durch sogenannte "toxikologische Studien".
Also Experimente mit Zellen oder mit Tieren,
wo man die gesundheitsschädliche Wirkung
auch biomechanistisch ziemlich genau nachvollziehen
kann.
Fazit: entweder haben die Lungenärzte Korrelation
und Kausalität nicht richtig verstanden oder
sie stellen es bewusst einseitig dar.
Zweitens: Störfaktoren.
Sie schreiben hier ganz richtig - und das
haben wir gerade auch schon angeschnitten
- "Die Krankheitshäufigkeit und die Lebenserwartung
werden durch zahlreiche Faktoren bestimmt".
Beispiel: ich vergleiche jetzt Menschen, die
in der Stadt leben und Menschen, die auf dem
Land leben.
Jetzt haben die Menschen in der Stadt mehr
Luftverschmutzung als die auf dem Land, dafür
haben die Menschen auf dem Land zum Beispiel
auch mehr Bewegung.
Und die Bewegung wirkt sich ja auch positiv
auf deren Gesundheit aus.
Und das muss ich berücksichtigen.
Wenn mir das bewusst ist und ich die Bewegung
ebenfalls beobachte, dann kann ich das in
meiner Datenauswertung sinnvoll rausrechnen.
Köhler und Co sagen hierzu: "Ein sogenanntes
Adjustieren der Einflüsse in den Studien
durch Fragebögen ist [..] wissenschaftsmethodologisch
nicht zulässig."
Übersetzt heißt das: dieses rausrechnen
ist methodisch nicht korrekt und man sollte
es deswegen lassen, weil es die Realität
zu sehr verzerrt.
Und manchmal stimmt das auch.
Genau das Problem hatten wir zum Beispiel
bei unserem Video über Alkohol, wo die Abstinenzler,
also die die gar keinen Alkohol tranken, sich
so stark von den anderen unterschieden, dass
man sie nicht mehr sinnvoll in die Auswertung
mit reinnehmen konnte.
Aber mit einem guten Studiendesign kann man
versuchen, solche Dinge zu vermeiden, in dem
man zum Beispiel die Studienteilnehmer so
auswählt, dass sie möglichst viel gemeinsam
haben.
Und die Studien, auf die sich unsere offiziellen
Grenzwerte beziehen, sind ordentlich designed.
Auch die Behauptung, dass "Lebensstil und
Gesundheitsbewusstsein nicht erfasst werden"
stimmt nicht so ganz.
Denn zum Beispiel erfasst man sehr oft den
sozioökonomischen Status, der zumindest sehr
viel verrät über Gesundheitsbewusstsein
und Lebensstil.
Fazit: wohlbekannte Herausforderungen, für
die es gängige Methoden gibt, werden hier
fälschlicherweise zu einem systematischen
und unlösbaren Fehler aufgebauscht.
Damit machen die Lungenärzte den gesamten
Fachbereich der Epidemiologie schlecht, wobei
sie selbst wohlgemerkt fachfremd sind. #lungenarztplaining
quasi.
Drittens: Schwellenwert und Toxizitätsmuster.
Hier versteh ich die Argumentation nicht ganz.
Sie Sagen bei Stickoxiden und Feinstaub gibt
es keinen Schwellenwert, also keine Konzentration,
bei der sie ungefährlich wäre.
Und das stimmt.
Es gilt stattdessen einfach: je mehr, desto
höher das Risiko.
Ich kann nur sagen: die offiziellen Grenzwerte
sind natürlich eine politische Abwägung.
Unsere Gesundheit auf der einen Seite und
Machbarkeit und Kosten auf der anderen Seite.
Und die Höhe des Grenzwertes, hier im Fall
Feinstaub und Stickoxide, die hängt von Machbarkeit
und Kosten ab.
Denn rein gesundheitlich betrachtet (Sirenengeräusche)
- jetzt passenderweise der Krankenwagen.
Rein gesundheitlich gilt hier: je weniger
Luftverschmutzung, desto besser.
Punkt.
Im nächsten Abschnitt sagen sie "Feinstaub
und NOX haben kein typisches, charakteristisches
Krankheitsbild wie zum Beispiel Rauchen und
Lungenkrebs oder Raucherbein, sondern es sind
viele verschiedene Krankheiten.
Und sie sagen weil es hier kein typisches
Vergiftungsmuster gibt, spricht das gegen
eine Gefährdung.
Also diese Argumentation überzeugt mich jetzt
überhaupt nicht, denn [z.B.]
Bewegungsmangel hat auch kein typisches Krankheitsbild,
sondern begünstigt eine ganze Vielzahl von
Krankheiten.
Genau dasselbe bei Schlafmangel wozu wir ja
auch noch ein ganzes Video haben, so nebenbei.
Fazit: Ein Schwellenwert sowie ein typisches
Krankheitsbild sind keine Voraussetzung für
einen anerkannten Giftstoff.
Doch wird das hier fälschlicherweise so dargestellt.
Next!
Falsifikation.
So jetzt kommt ihr "stärkstes Argument".
Sie sagen Zigarettenrauch enthält ja Unmengen
mehr Stickoxide und Feinstaub als ich jetzt
auf der Straße einatme und darüber hinaus
ja noch viel mehr andere schädliche Stoffe.
Das stimmt.
Das heißt sie sagen jetzt hier, wenn ein
Raucher x-mal so viel Stickoxide inhaliert
wie ich jetzt auf der Straße, dann müssten
Raucher ja auch x-fach früher sterben.
Und nach ihren eigenen Berechnungen, die jetzt
hier nicht näher aufgeschlüsselt sind, müssten
die meisten Raucher nach wenigen Monaten alle
versterben, was offensichtlich nicht der Fall
ist.
Update: inzwischen ist rausgekommen, dass
hier ein Rechenfehler vorliegt.
Es wären nicht ein paar Monate, sondern ein
paar Jahre und Dieter Köhler hat diesen Rechenfehler
auch schon eingeräumt und sagt, das ändert
aber nichts an der Tatsache.
Und da gebe ich ihm Recht, denn das eigentliche
Problem steckt ganz woanders.
Um dem zu entgegnen klau ich mir mal hier
einen Ausschnitt von meinen Kollegen bei "Terra
X Lesch & Co", weil da wurde es schon perfekt
beantwortet: Das Risiko flacht ab.
Ein Raucher der Hundert Zigaretten raucht
im Vergleich zu jemanden der eine Zigarette
raucht am Tag hat ja auch nicht ein hundertfach
erhöhtes Risiko.
Und so ähnlich ist es auch in Bezug auf das
Passivrauchen: das heißt Rauch in Innenräumen
kann auch zum Beispiel Herzinfarkte auslösen,
aber da ist das Risiko 50% erhöht, während
ein Raucher ein 100% erhöhtes Risiko hat.
Und wenn man das jetzt runter sieht auf den
Feinstaub, dann ist das Risiko insgesamt kleiner,
aber dem Feinstaub sind wir Tag und Nacht
ausgesetzt.
Und auch alle Bevölkerungsgruppen.
Fazit: Die x-fache Konzentration führt eben
nicht zu einem x-fach früheren Sterben.
Ein solcher linearer Zusammenhang besteht
hier überhaupt nicht.
Die Rechnung der Lungenärzte ist also schlicht
und einfach im Grundprinzip falsch.
Rechenfehler hin oder her.
So viel zum "stärksten Argument".
Es kann gut sein, dass ich als erwachsener,
gesunder Mensch auch höhere Konzentrationen
von Feinstaub und Stickoxiden problemlos wegstecke.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch Kinder auf unseren
Straßen und Ältere und Menschen die bereits
Lungen- oder Atemprobleme haben.
Und wenn es um die Luft geht da draußen,
dann müssen wir die gesundheitlich Schwächsten
in unserer Gesellschaft unbedingt schützen.
Denn wir haben ja alle keine Wahl, wir müssen
ja alle atmen.
Deswegen finde ich strenge Grenzwerte bei
Luftverschmutzung richtig.
Das Statement endet mit einer ziemlich unverschämten
Unterstellung.
Sie fordern nämlich eine Neubewertung der
wissenschaftlichen Studien durch unabhängige
Forscher.
Damit wird ja impliziert, dass die Forscher
bisher nicht unabhängig waren; was eine freche
Unterstellung ist, für die hier noch nicht
mal Begründungen geliefert werden.
Das sind keine Experten hier.
Das sind Hundert Menschen die ziemlich unwissenschaftliche
Aussagen unterschrieben haben und die stehen
gegen tausende Expertinnen und Experten.
Doch in Talkshows kriegt man dann den Eindruck
hier steht Aussage gegen Aussage.
"False Balance" nennt man das.
Ich finde das geht gar nicht.
Und deswegen - und ihr wisst, ich bitte euch
nicht oft darum, aber dieses Mal - bitte teilt
dieses Video.
Denn so ein unwissenschaftlicher Unfug darf
nicht einfach so akzeptiert werden.
Das war jetzt wie gesagt die wissenschaftliche
Basis: Feinstaub und Stickoxide sind nicht
cool - wollen wir reduzieren.
Wie man jetzt die konkret reduziert und ob
Dieselfahrverbote dabei wirklich helfen, das
sind noch mal ganz andere Fragen und diese
Fragen werden wir am Mittwoch bei Maischberger
diskutieren.
Also wenn dieses Video rauskommt, dann war
ich schon bei Maischberger.
Das Thema war Dieselgrenzwerte/Fahrverbote.
Ich werde euch den Link zur Mediathek in die
Videobeschreibung packen.
Und falls ihr große Freunde der Sonne seid
und nicht verpassen wollt, wenn ich mal im
Fernsehen bin - ich bin ja auch zum Beispiel
bei Quarks - dann könnt ihr mir bei Instagram
oder Twitter folgen, dann kündige ich sowas
auch immer an, dann erfahrt ihr das auch rechtzeitig.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche, bis dahin - bleibt
sicher.